I've had a lot of interviews where I've
been accused of like
>> I'm not accusing you at all. And his
mother claims he was murdered
on your orders.
Do you believe that? I I'm Well, I'm I'm
asked
>> I mean you just said it, so do you do
you believe that? That was Sam Altman,
the CEO of OpenAI, one of the most
powerful people on planet Earth being
accused on camera of murder. And Sam
doesn't run off, he barely even
flinches, he doesn't lawyer up. Instead,
he offers us what I think is a
masterclass in how to handle difficult
questions on the spot. Now, depending on
what you think of Sam, you might find
some of his answers to be elusive or
even suspicious. Some of you will think
he's really impressive, but the point
here is there is so much to learn about
how Sam handles these difficult
situations with high stakes in the
moment.
>> mother claims he was murdered
on your orders.
Do you believe that? When Sam responds
to this insane tension accusation, he
doesn't match the temperature in the
room. He responds really calmly. You
understand [music] how this sounds like
an accusation. Most people think they
have two choices when someone asks them
a difficult question.
First, you can accept the question at
face value. Sam could say,
"No, of course not. I didn't order a
murder. Here's what actually happened."
But now he's defending himself against a
murder accusation in front of millions
of people, and that's already a horrible
look, guilty or innocent. The second
option would be to push back, to match
the intensity of the situation. So this
would be like Sam saying, "This is
outrageous. I can't believe you would
say something like that." And, you know,
standing up and banging his fist, but
then he'd look guilty and he'd look
unhinged. So instead he does something
that's so much more interesting. [music]
You understand how this sounds like an
accusation. Instead of accepting the
accusation or denying it, all Sam does
is he points out that there is an
accusation [music] being made. You can
imagine that in that moment, internally,
he must be boiling. He must want to get
up and scream. He's thinking all these
thoughts like so much is happening. He's
wondering what we're thinking about him
and that this is going to go out there,
that there's no way for it not to be
published and all these different
things, yet we see none of that.
We see somebody who is so calm and
composed. What he's doing,
we call staying in character at Ultra
Speaking. He knows that unless he shows
you and tells you what's happening
inside, that we can't see it. We're not
transparent. So this concept of staying
in character is saying, "Regardless of
what's happening internally, I'm not
going to share my insecurities with my
[music] audience."
So you can use this when you're in your
meeting, when you know that there's a
high stakes situation coming up,
you can mentally prepare yourself and
say, "Hey, regardless of what I'm going
to feel internally,
I don't need to share this with my
audience because they can't see it in
the first place. So the way you practice
this, you pay attention to situations
where you slightly break character.
Everybody's doing this all the time. You
snicker, you kind of laugh at the end of
a sentence of something you said that
didn't feel very right. You make a
grimace, you apologize for something you
say. If you bring awareness to those
situations, you're going to be able to
start staying in character more. To
notice that I said something that came
out wrong, but I don't need to show it
to you. I can keep on going and nobody
will pick up on it. Nobody will pay
attention [music] or give it weight. And
if you do this enough, this is going to
blend into the more high stakes
scenarios of your life. So that's move
one, and it's incredibly valuable,
incredibly important because it will
immediately make you come off as more
confident and having more conviction. So
here's move two.
And I will totally say when I first
heard about this, it sounded very
suspicious.
>> Okay, so I'm not reaching I'm not being
crazy here.
>> Well, but then after the second thing
came out and the more detail, I was
like, "Okay." If Sam had said, "I don't
find this suspicious at all," then our
suspicions would have gone through the
roof. It would have been game over right
there. But instead, he very simply says,
"Yeah, I also thought that was kind of
suspicious at first." He's acknowledging
very simply what the other party is
saying before he says what he wants to
say. And he does this many, many times.
If I were his family, I am sure I would
want answers and I'm sure I would not be
satisfied [music]
with really any I mean there's nothing
that would comfort me in that, you know.
Right. I think you can totally take the
point that you're just trying to get to
the truth of what happened and [music] I
respect that. When Sam acknowledges what
Tucker's saying, you might think
intuitively that it may lessen his point
and lessen the probability of Tucker
actually believing
>> [music]
>> what Sam is saying.
But it's actually the opposite. Because
if I say something that I believe,
imagine you're in a team meeting and
you're presenting something [music] to
me, a feature request, and I respond
with a worry I have, [music] and you
don't listen to me in the sense that you
don't repeat back what I said, you don't
acknowledge what I said, but you counter
with something else, then I will
naturally feel like you didn't hear what
I just said, even if you did. Cuz what
Sam does is when he acknowledges
[music]
below. If you like this breakdown, I
really think you're going to like my
previous video on Brené Brown and how
she uses prompts to increase her
conviction when she speaks. Check it out
right here.